If you want to be good,
do what they say you should,
but if you want to be great,
you innovate.
Whitney Wolfe Herd,
CEO and founder of Bumble.
The youngest woman
to take a company public.
We need to rewrite the rules.
Let's do it.
I will speak
vulnerably about
the difficulties
I'm having somewhere.
To see a leader be vulnerable,
c
it makes people feel connected.
Contrary to popular belief,
Bumble started with a
pretty modest budget.
We had to be really thoughtful
and really, really creative.
I'm going to show
you how to do that too.
Don't hold yourself back
by society's
perception of who you are.
Why aren't we being the masters
of our own destiny?
I'm Whitney Wolfe Herd,
and this is MasterClass.